i don't feel sorry for us
even though we have this huge gap
in our lives
we have this
huge hole
and our lives will never be the same
i feel sorry for her she lost everything
it's been less than a week since her
niece was killed but zara elena's aunt
refuses to let her memory be defined by
her death
when she walked in we have a word in
urdu it's ronak
it means joy the the the light
of our home
that's what she was
an aspiring lawyer the 35 year old had
just started a job at the royal courts
of justice a 29 year old man jordan
mcsweeney has been charged with her
murder she was on the road
towards her dreams you know she was she
had her foot on that step
both of them firmly planted on that step
attacked at 2 17 a.m in the street in
ilford it was an area she knew and felt
safe in
on saturday a vigil will be held here
zara's family friends and members of the
community in which she lived will gather
here in silence to walk the rest of her
10-minute journey home a journey that
she never got to complete
the family vow to bring about change
they want the world to know elena was
fierce she was independent but most of
all this wasn't her fault
we bring her home we bring zara home
safely
we're sending a message to zara
that she wasn't wrong
she didn't do anything wrong
that's the most important thing
that she didn't do anything wrong adele
robinson sky news